hello I'm marketing chick I'm the chief
technology officer for evolved analytics
today I will be talking about GUI
development from a practitioner
perspective what we have in a lot of the
data modeler excuse me a lot of the what
the Wolfram documentation is operating
at at the dictionary level rather than
sort of a holistic system building level
so what do I talk about is that holistic
system building so that the notebook
here the slide deck is is on the server
so you turn the volume down just a
little so it's it's out there we're
going to blip through a lot of stuff in
the in a short amount of time so I just
want to put together as a slide deck for
reference material so what's I mean
what's the advantage of a GUI versus a
notebook a notebook is a wonderful thing
that's better
notebooks wonderful thing but it's got
this linear view it's got an audit trail
the problem is the sequence matters and
you've got this sort of long-distance
interaction so they're you know dropping
into a long analysis you know if I
forget to evaluate an earlier cell I'm
sort of hosed so that but the plus of
notebook interfaces with no limits
whereas in a GUI and so what we have
here ins is an analysis notebook using
data modeler versus the data modeler GUI
I mean so now you've got this sort of
nonlinear interaction be able to flow
jump around say okay this you know these
variables in this case look interesting
let's pop back looks look at their
properties and and be able to flip
around we also hide the complexity and
the design but the design limits the
functionality that can be good you'd get
you ease of use but it's it's got some
downsides so what we're going to do real
quick is is talk about some of the
motivations a little bit about
manipulate talk about how to layout
GUI within Mathematica development
environments running through some of the
nuts and bolts of dynamic and then
finish up with some of the system
building issues around deployment and IP
protection GUI is you know wonderful you
got this sort of not natural nonlinear
workflow that's a big plus of it we've
got a lot of people in the world that
can't handle holding down the shift key
while they hit Enter you know hide that
complexity of that don't have to know
naming conventions of mathematic and all
that sort of stuff
big big wins for gooeys for for Joe
Schmo user credentials for myself an
aerial data modeler is one of the the
largest gooeys bill 100% pure
Mathematica
but I've also built an image analyzers
as well as knitting pattern for start
off as my wife's birthday present Ariel
has you know we collaborated on the data
modeler GUI he's also got a number of
products as well as his own consulting
work one thing here you know so sorry so
just this is a response contour plot
Explorer one of the things about the GUI
when just as we start to do it note the
the use of field hints that's something
as you build it to guide the the
behavior of the users so what's you know
what's great about manipulators is it so
fast do quick and dirty it's got
intelligent defaults and you can get
something that's reasonably decent in in
a fairly quick time this was for a
client that was a professional baseball
team just sort of looking at the at
pitch state transitions of the various
counts what's going to happen just you
know statistic there's there's close to
million pitches per year in the in Major
League Baseball so a lot of data there
[Music]
what's wrong with manipulate is that it
just doesn't really scale well to maybe
we get something more sophisticated I
put this this is the initial
instantiation of the the knitting
software for from Oh light you know 50
60 lines of Mathematica code and you've
got something sort of neat to to play
around with slipping stitches and
creating argyle patterns and and all you
know defining colors pretty neat the
problem is when you start to go to the
next level then it sort of runs out of
steam but manipulates handy just as a
general thing we did gotten into a
consulting project and doing image
analysis of microscopy 3d stacks of
images you know and mathematic is
fantastic oK you've got all these
capabilities and you've got all these
options and you've got options on the
options and so so now you know you know
everything's in there how do I design a
flow so I wrote this this little
Explorer to let me sort of sequence the
operations and to get the behavior I
wanted out of the against the data sets
and let's see so anyhow you know a lot
of capabilities buried in there in a
fairly succinct exercise when you're
doing a GUI tab view and open reviews
really your your friend you want to sort
of layout the structure first and then
start populating it iteratively with
with capabilities but you know so these
are the tools and the and the
functionalities you care about as you
work the other one thing that's
important is to care about your you're
not everybody is running on a 27-inch
iMac with oodles of screen real estate
you got it you got to respect the 11
inch MacBook Air and be able to let
people
handle you know that sort of variety
very important once you get to a certain
level of complexity is shifting over a
workbench you know you've got a lot Buie
code unlike normal Mathematica code is
pretty verbose so so what you want to do
I mean you just sort of need the
workbench environment in order to manage
that code to do the replacements thing
that's very important is in workbench
you've run the code under the control of
Mathematica underneath workbench because
those dynamics can run amok so easily
and when they run them out then you have
to kill the kernel and then you lose all
your code edits if you're operating in a
Mathematica notebook here at least
you're separated and you get a chance to
get back control and and degrade
gracefully and recover from from that
you know just to give you an idea of
where we're at scale wise data model
there's thirty thousand lines of code
the GUI is another fifteen thousand
lines I mean there's a lot of
functionality there but I mean it's just
naturally you know it's still more
verbose I'd also go for coding
conventions and and lesson learned the
hard way for for my image analysis stuff
document as you go because you know use
the workbench to do the documentation
and and make sure you know what your
functions really are doing then once you
have once you have the basic structure
of of your interface then you start have
to populate it with controls and
displays there's just lots of things in
there the sliders the switch it's very
rich you know color setter is wonderful
because we got into trying to do some
stuff as an iOS app and there turns out
you don't have a color setter in iOS
it's just sort of an amazing thing
but you really want to you know care
about the layout and the controls and
the interface and the aesthetics are
very important in my view so this is the
you know a view within data modeler
looking at some some models that have
been developed there's a lot actually
buried in this thing from from a design
aesthetics perspective all right see so
here the input set had 240 variables
that we're trying to sort through so
just as a thing we've heard that okay so
one first thing palette palettes the
nice thing but they don't have to be
ugly I mean that seems to be the
convention in in Mathematica that
palettes are ugly but using some colors
you know highlighting because the users
are really basically largely it's gonna
care about launching the GUI or else
launching an analysis notebook there's a
workflow to the analysis so we put the
tabs on the top so you can click through
and bounce back and forth but there's a
natural support for that workflow and
and the cycle and also the ability to
bounce back and forth Jimmy you get into
a mathematical long mathematic notebook
now I you know I've got some results I'm
gonna go back and look at the data which
is you know way back in the beginning I
got to get there so you know being able
to use these tabs to two bounces is
important important thing if you're
building a GUI
you know logical filenames you know help
the user out give me file names give
them timestamps for the file so that
they don't overwrite over write things
in this in our case we have variable set
C you know I started off with 240
variables I get it down to a lower
amount that I want to drill in let me
make it easy to get to that lower amount
again the openers the use of the openers
we go.we here we've got you know various
controls and explorers to look at our
developed bottles you know but
I can't show them all on screen at the
same time they don't need to all be on
screen on the tape same time I just have
to make it reasonably efficient to get
to those those views same deal you know
the Explorer controls here we have we're
looking at a variable presence chart for
for the variables and which ones have
emerged at the floor I can you know I've
got controls each each of the Explorer
functions have these controls but
they're hidden by default but easily
accessible you also have the ability I
mean one of the great things about a
notebook environment it's it's got this
natural audit trail so in this case
you've got to allow the user to to
create that audit the equivalent of that
audit trail and preserve results and do
the analyses tooltips are important I
mean you have to be little bit careful
about tooltips in Mathematica because
because a lot of them will bring the
front-end to its knees but it reduces
clutter visual clutter but still
provides you know insight when available
and then I guess finally the the you
know things that can be dynamic should
be dynamic so here the image size and
aspect ratio are dynamic so the user can
just slide that thing in the in the and
the plot scale you know quickly so you
don't have to to restructure recreate
the plots and and you know the analysis
to generate that view so a lot of
details went in there and this is just a
single slide with what I just talked
about now this is the image analyzer
project when you're dealing with stacks
of microscopy images just even loaded
and then the data takes time much annal
much less analyzing and extracting
information so a lifesigns
important out of this exercise
and you know eventually the the whole
point of this was to create a data set
that we could send it to date a model or
so so each stack would result in 1,200
attributes that we then sorted through
to say which ones were really affecting
the the characteristics of of interest
learned a lot in this process because I
I did the mistakes for you that I'm
talking about here as best practices
this is what the Knitting software has
has morphed into again a lot of stuff
but having a reset button is a good
thing to have in any of these interfaces
to let the user get back to a known
state this is a little bit a little bit
fun because entering stuff in some
actions areas you want to disable other
controls depending upon the states they
have keeping track of of those those
sorts of things and again tooltips
and field hamster are important from a
user perspective now you get into the
actual dynamic code and the wonderful
thing about dynamic is it improves your
vocabulary because you learn how to
swear and and and and sling things
together in new and novel ways you know
which you really have to do is is those
be methodical partitioned the
functionality really understand there's
a second argument to dynamic that's so
important to get the side effects that
you're really looking for so you've got
to do that the other thing here is you
know do not use track symbols on arrays
and images and large things if you get
it down to a counter or some sort of
something small to trigger that's going
to make for much more reliable and
responsive interface
dynamic not module by default in beds
it's information you know the stuff
that's applied to it in the dynamic
module so I mean this is great but here
here I've got you know could you know
fouls I can have thousands of variables
that are in my original data set this is
this is looking at the response behavior
of of a model what only three of the
variables are in my model because I've
done this analysis so before I saw I've
got functions wrapping there that are
not dynamic outside this thing which
says presents the dynamic module with
only the minimal information required
because I want to keep that footprint
small and make it responsive okay
so and you know and because that stuff
in beds layering so if you if you write
sequences of dynamic modules and then
layer them you get duplicate copies of
stuff unless you're careful well I
should also say that control active is
an important thing here because these
these response envelopes of uncertainty
changes I as I move my points around in
parameter space so we use control active
to reduce what's displayed while the
control is being used and then and then
you show the full view once it's
released and that leads a sort of
naturally into slow computations you
really have to be explicit about that
have to understand the differences
between synchronous synchronous updating
the states and also provide feedback
because if you have something that takes
30 seconds to evaluate people can't look
at a blank screen for 30 seconds without
clicking on on stuff and adding more
things to the queue and
breaking stuff
this little little detail on on life
side panels turns out that you within
the CDF you can't update a dialog box so
you know the pro chivor I used is to
actually write multiple windows and and
put one window on top of the next one
and delete the one below little little
bit of a sin of omission in input fields
in that if you if you restrict the input
field to to be a number and you enter in
George as the as the entry into the
input field well it doesn't display
George but the dynamic variable gets
reset to George which which you need to
use the second argument of dynamic in
order to trap these sorts of situations
lots of tooltips
will bring things to its knees the front
end to its knees you know keep it under
a thousand if you're you know don't
don't run amok there and then the the
other issue is that workbench is only
sort of marginally maintained I you know
there's hints of a refresh but you know
you really need to use it but we need
more support in that and then of course
I'm looking forward to a CDF
implementation of for the iPad when you
get to the notebook creation phase the
big one here is you want to put savable
to false so that people aren't prompted
to save the notebooks you can still do
that in terms of deployment of systems
when you build these buoys you know if
people have mathematic that's cool they
could you can just use the notebooks
directly CDF player pros about $200 a
pop to to hand off you know a license to
them alternately you can have Enterprise
Mathematica which is 10% of revenue with
the minimum
$12,000 that has the advantage that I
can create notebooks and just throw them
out and they can and the advantage of
the the the enter the CDF player Pro and
the enterprise is that the notebooks
that you create or the gooeys that you
can create can read and write data so
they're not you know they're more
dynamic and I haven't looked at anything
around the the cloud stuff best
practices basically good design good
development
[Music]
you know don't write spaghetti code you
guys can read this you know sort of
offline I don't think that's you know
developed functions that you reuse as
part of your notebook for example the
all those openers every every opener and
data model or we've we're doing these
explorers well--that's has a common
frame so there's you know there's a
function there and we've separated the
data from the functionality so so it's
more maintainable okay and don't make it
ugly
so speaking more best best practices I
do by my pitch for Ariel and his
software again I mean he's he
understands dynamic better far better
than I do as well as as interface design
one issue is for intellectual property
you don't have you don't have you know
what you store is the CDF by default is
just plain text so I mean it's it's
there if you don't want that to be there
use encode and do some other stuff to
get our lock down you can lock down to a
machine ID if if that's appropriate and
then you know my advice would be script
the encoding so this is the this is the
data modeler GUI
in a code that's that's displayed to the
world so conclusion
I love gooeys level I hate GUI
development but if you're disciplined
you're you can get to success and it's
it's not to honor us and there's contact
information for me as well as aerial and
that wraps me up so we have two minutes
for questions if there if there is
[Applause]